you've seen that supervised machine
learning algorithms can classify your
data
unsupervised machine learning algorithms
can cluster your data
now let's look at an entirely different
set of algorithms based on conditional
probability
say you're looking to see how one thing
impacts the probability of another thing
happening
the most popular algorithm for this type
of analysis
is called the bayesian algorithm based
on the base theory of statistics
naive bayes is one of the most popular
bayesian machine learning algorithms
it's called naive because it assumes
that all of the predictors are
independent
from one another naive bayes is mostly
used for binary or multi-class
classification
let's go back to our animal shelter in
chicago
imagine that we wanted to classify all
the dogs in the shelter
based on their different breeds remember
that there are hundreds of different dog
breeds
on top of that most dogs would be a
mixture of several breeds
let's look at this problem using a naive
bayes machine learning algorithm
to start let's create three classes of
dog breeds
we'll use terrier hounds and sport dogs
now for each of these classes we'll have
three predictors
let's use hair length height and weight
remember that some of the predictors
will be closely autocorrelated
a tall dog is more likely to be heavier
but naive bayes considers each one of
these predictors independently
remember that's why it's called naive
once you have your classes and
predictors set up then the naive bayes
machine learning algorithm starts with
something called class predictor
probability
this is when it looks at each of the
independent predictors and tries to
create a probability that the dog
belongs in each class
let's see what happens when you're
trying to identify an unknown dog
the first predictor you look at is hair
length
the machine learning algorithm can check
the probability of a dog with this hair
length
belonging to any of the three classes it
finds that a dog with this hair length
has a forty percent chance of being a
terrier
a ten percent chance of being a hound
and a 50
chance that it's a sport dog the next
thing you check
is the unknown dog's height again
naive bayes doesn't correlate the dog's
hair length with the dog's height
it looks at this predictor independently
and tries to calculate the probability
that this unknown dog will belong to
each class
so again it looks at the training data
and finds that there's a twenty percent
chance that it's a terrier
a ten percent chance that it's a hound
and a seventy percent chance that it's a
sport dog
the final thing you want to check is the
unknown dog's weight
this might seem like a strange predictor
because it's closely related to height
but remember the naive bayes is
evaluating the probability of each
predictor independently
it looks at the training data and finds
there's a ten percent chance it's a
terrier
a five percent chance that it's a hound
and an eighty five percent chance that
it's a sport dog
you now have this table with the unknown
dog's class predictor probability
if you look at it you can see that the
dog is probably a sport dog
but remember most machine learning
problems are dealing with terabytes or
even petabytes of dog data
and is trying to classify millions of
unknown dogs
to classify your dog you might want to
use something called the weighted
multiplication function
since this is a weighted function the
first thing you want to do is create a
weight
it's here you'll decide which one of
your predictors is the most predictive
you can pick this weight by looking at
the training data
you can also tweak it if it improves
your accuracy
here we'll use a weight of 3 for hair
and 2 for weight and height
for the weighted multiplication function
take the predictor and multiply it by
your weight
when you add up the predictors for hair
length height and weight
you can see that the second unknown dog
is most likely a sport dog
it's less likely that it's a terrier and
very unlikely that it's a hound